bonjour l'oni besançon merci beaucoup
d'être avec tous nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france jusqu'à présent
on allait parler d'un d'une certaine
exception suédoise est ce que ce n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui selon vous avez
effectivement parler de ça beaucoup il
ya eu beaucoup de discours là dessus je
pense que ce qu'il faut considérer un
première chose c'est que il y avait
effectivement une forme d'exception ce
qui a aidé de confinement suédois aux
appareils de mesure très très restrictif
néanmoins y avait quelques mesures
restrictives déjà pendant la première
vague effectivement là on arrive
doucement vers de mesures beaucoup plus
restrictive que le gouvernement essaie
de faire passer pour le 10 janvier
environ on arrive peut-être vers la fin
d'une exception mais c'était plus ou
moins logiques on avait vu avec la
première vague déjà que la stratégie
avait pas été très efficace le début de
la 2eme montrer que ça allait pas être
vraiment mieux on probablement bien pire
donc effectivement je pense qu'on passe
plus ou moins s'aligner maintenant sur
les pays voisins qui sont sa langue le
danemark deux mesures un peu plus
restrictive notamment ce qui concerne
effectivement le port du masque vous
l'avais dit dans le reportage mais aussi
dense en ce qui concerne la limitation
des 30 de fréquentation des lieux
publics donc notamment les magasins je
pense justement qu'est ce qui a motivé
ce changement de cap ça veut dire que la
population ne suivaient pas jusque là
les recommandations du gouvernement
c'est un petit peu difficile à dire je
pense qu'il ya eu plusieurs choses qui
en jouait en fait faut savoir aussi
quelque chose c'est que pendant la
première vague y avait déjà eu une
proposition comme comme celle ci avait
été plus ou moins rejetés enfin pas
clairement mais qui avait été amoindrie
par le parlement avant d'être votée qui
l'avait rendu presque en fait inutile et
donc elle avait expiré en juin sans
avoir été utilisé au mois de septembre
il y avait eu déjà de la part de
l'institut de santé deux du gouvernement
qui puiseront démesure des idées qui
parlait de confinement locaux est
limitée dans le temps d'accès pas je
pense que les s'est pas vraiment il le
fait que les suédois ne respectaient pas
les les recommandations c'était surtout
le fait qu'on pratique s'était passé en
fait c'était clairement pas assez
pourtant le bilan est pas si mauvais
puisque la suède n'a pas eu de
confinement elle est presqu'au niveau
des autres pays européens
néanmoins
ces mesures avaient été jugé très pro
liberté si je puis dire alors qu'en
france les beaucoup de personnes se sont
érigés contre les lois dickie
liberticide est cité notamment la suède
en exemple est-ce que ce cette liberté
est chère aux suédois oui plus ou moins
je suis vraiment convaincu que ce soit
le souci en fait j'ai pas l'impression
avec beaucoup de suédois ici j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit vraiment un cas
de liberté à respecter ou non c'est plus
le fait que c'était pas réellement
possible à la constitution suédoise
effectivement la suède a beaucoup des
cités par d'autres pays qui ont su lee
un confinement pour dire que l'on
pouvait faire sans après ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que bon la suède fait à peu
près aussi comme vous l'avait dit avant
les autres pays européens
mais oui aussi mal que les autres pays
européens mais par rapport aux voisins
nordiques elle fait clairement pire on
peut parler de quatre fois le nombre de
décès par million d'habitants de ses
voisins nordiques ce qui est ce qui est
terrible et comparer avec la france ou
l'allemagne c'est un petit peu compliqué
puisqu'on voit qu'on en compte beaucoup
de facteurs dont comment fonctionne le
système de santé comme les la
démographie donc la démographie ça va
être l'âge moyen mais ça met aussi la
densité de population je veux savoir que
paris puisse banlieue c'est la
population d'assurer dans entière par
exemple donc la densité population à
paris lé 5 à 6 fois supérieure la
densité population à stockholm d'un
guide cdc genre de facteurs lassé des
facteurs qui vont clairement aider à la
propagation d'un virus donc la suède au
départ est un pays qui avait tout pour
réussir parce que mal et j'en avais déjà
la distance sociale ça existait avant
avant que vides ici un les gens dans le
bus ne s'assoit pas connaître quelqu'un
d'autre qui a une place disponible le
plus loin possible
c'est ce genre de choses là qu'il
faudrait que la suède comme la finlande
comme le danemark la norvège avait des
facteurs plus ou moins idée au départ
pour une pour une pandémie
finalement la suisse s'en sort pas si
bien que ça parce que le port du masque
a mis plus de 10 mois est recommandé par
exemple parce que les limitations sur
les lieux publics ont pas été assez
forte je pense donc faut quand même un
petit peu relativiser ça je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire que la suède as plus
ou moins sauver ses libertés puis avec
anne des recommandations à ses formes de
temps en temps en ce qui concerne
l'économie spy on a vu si on compare
avec les voisins nordiques on voit que
la suède fait au moins pire au moins
aussi bien on va dire que les voisins
nordiques mais souvent pire si on
compare la finlande la norvège donc
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment une
vingtaine il a été efficace
merci à vous l'oni besançon d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france votre
intervention
depuis stockholm en suède